واعتدلوا
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج ولا
تختلفوا فتختلف قلوبكم
anys
صلى الله عليه ‏Pleas
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم
ر
تلك ايات الكتاب وقران مبين
ربما يود الذين كفروا لو كانوا مسلمين
ذرهم ياكلوا ويتمتعوا
ويلههم الامل فسوف يعلمون
وما اهلكنا من قريه الا ولها كتاب معلوم
ما تسبق من امه اجلها وما يستاخرون
وقالوا يا ايها الذي نزل عليه الذكر انك
لمجنون
لو ما تاتينا بالملائكه
ان كنت من الصادقين
ما ننزل الملائكه
الا بالحق وما كانوا اذا منظرين
انا نحن نزلنا الذكر وانا له لحافظون
ولقد ارسلنا من قبلك في شيع الاولين
وما ياتيهم من رسول الا كانوا به يستهزئون
كذلك نسلكه في قلوب المجرمين
لا يؤمنون به وقد خلت سنه الاولين
ولو فتحنا عليهم بابا من السماء
فظلوا فيه يعرجون
لقالوا انما سكرت ابصارنا بل نحن قوم
مسحورون
ولقد جعلنا في السماء
بروجا وزيناها
للناظرين
وحفظناها
من كل شيطان رجيم
الا من استرق السم
فاتبعه شهاب مبين
والارض مددناها والقينا فيها رواسي
وانبتنا
فيها
فيها من كل شيء موزون
وجعلنا لكم فيها معايش وما ومن لستم له
برازقين
وان من شيء الا عندنا خزائنه
وما ننزله الا بقدر
معلوم
وارسلنا الرياح لواقح فانزلنا
من السماء
ماء
فاسقيناكموه
وما انتم له بخازنين
وانا لنحن نحيي ونميت ونحن الوارثون
ولقد علمنا المستقدمين
منكم ولقد علمنا المستاخرين
وان ربك هو يحشرهم انه حكيم عليم
ولقد خلقنا الانسان من صلصال
من حما مسنون
والجان
خلقناه من قبل من نار السموم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
يا رب
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واذ قال ربك للملائكه
اني خالق بشرا
اني خالق بشرا من صلصال من حما مسنون
فاذا سويته ونفخت فيه من روحي فقعوا له
ساجدين
فسجد الملائكه
كلهم اجمعون
الا ابليس ابى ان يكون مع الساجدين
قال يا ابليس ما منعك الا تكون مع
الساجدين
[Arabic recitation]
قال يا ابليس ما لك الا تكون مع الساجدين
قال لم اكن لاسجد لبشر خلقته من صلصال من
حما مسنون
قال فاخرج منها فانك رجيم
وان عليك اللعنه الى يوم الدين
قال رب فانظرني
الى يوم يبعثون
قال فانك من المنظرين
الى يوم الوقت المعلوم
قال رب بما اغويتني لازينن
لهم في الارض ولاغوينهم
اجمعين
الا عبادك منهم المخلصين
قال هذا صراط علي مستقيم
ان عبادي ليس لك عليهم سلطان
ليس لك عليهم سلطان الا من اتبع عك من
الغاوين
وان جهنم
لموعدهم اجمعين
لها سبعه ابواب لكل باب منهم جزء مقسوم
ان المتقين في جنات
وعيون
ادخلوها
بسلام
امنين
ونزعنا ما في صدورهم
من غل اخوانا على سرر متقابلين
لا يمسهم فيها نصب وما هم منها بمخرجين
نبئ عبادي اني
انا الغفور الرحيم
وان عذابي هو العذاب الاليم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
التحيات لله والصلتيبات
والسلام عليك ونبي
وسلم عليك
مولانا مولانا
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
رب العالمين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم الصراط
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر اللهم
انت السلام عليكم السلام
[Silence]
அலைக்கும்
பிரதர் சிஸ்டர்ஸ்
மெஷன் கதி
‏I think yesterday pleas not make don in
the paring lots
hope you understand that ter
are c of reasons why we don't want the
cars to be driving f in the parking lot
one is it kicks up the dust second
unsafe for the neh and definல if we
continue do that the ‏neb
is with that and we do not want to do
the other thing that we need to be
watchful for is par responsility
wherever you parক we have lot of paring
now but sometimes if you have to walk
few sts please make that effort rather
than trying to find the most expedit and
closest part for yourself so if you can
please keep in you know those things in
জd
[Silence]
সন্ড
পারক
পার্কিং
‏No matter howting that is pleas do not
park even if there is a vant sping
pleas do not do that because this is of
respect so they have asked for itdays
and pleas that
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والعاقبه للمتقين ولا عدوان الا على
الظالمين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
هو يتولى الصالحين واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما
سنه
first
is
all
‏our
what is among humanity
is each and person us think
and people think
they different the never
‏think are untouchable
all those nations before us that wcked
and droed
not us we would never
as a matter of fact here in America
it is so arrant
that it has reach
‏unalfold
only would come to end is if came to end
otherwi
we are a fi of humanity we were always
meant to be and we are different and
special this is exactly
the attitude
وى
‏female thinks is beautiful thing that
has ever walked the earth no one is ever
as beautiful and smart as
and
thinks that he is just the toughest most
smartest guy ever death would never come
for me no I'm special I have a special
purpose.
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
ايبتغون عندهم العزه
فان العزه
ايش لله
جميعا
seurity
عزه
other الله
in
personesek
in their profession in their care you
know the word career
career
‏you have care not
have care
and care
weve got women that will trade their
families and their husbands for their
career
myacy
weve got that
‏on each other's ne in
cut way because their career and don't
hate the player hate the game
right and we call greed ambition
and we call selfcenteredness and
arrogance strength of character and
selfestem
this
‏something if enough people to ad it a
isleell
in body
of us is aleell in a body we all make up
one body
and whatever thoseells are doing is what
that body will be
and so
right
‏our
we have lally spilled the bl ofle
nation on this
in 250 years not even 250 years
america has been at legitimate
‏How many generations of people
and so the idea is
not us we to powerful
we have F16
well that's the 90s F what 23 F 54 we
have AI
we have skynet
‏have all
the nations that came before us they
haveancy stuff that's why we are
different
when we oppress
god is with us
this is the idea and this perversion of
thought is what to the fall of emp ire
came before even the musl emp ire
‏Em iream
roughly about 300 yearsorically
speaking 300 years and western
historians place the fall and collapse
of societies into six stages.
‏onl
schires
goes.
‏is decadence
extremely
weak selfcentered people who do nothing
but eat and dev and consume all of the
work of their ancestors until they
hollow out their own
and then
the bottom comes out and a society falls
just a human being has a natural
lifan
someer
and
question now
will
never been moreely to
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
مكه المدينه
told us
he said and
‏and if any
will
come
after a great famon has sw the
and in some prophecies he comes with a
mountain of meat and bread
and he calls a
‏him with
from upon their crops and he withholds
the soil from growing their crops and
their die and they in their fam
and the propet
tells us that
the riches the treasures of old will
follow
‏and man will have
up his wife and his mother and his
daughter from going to join a
because they are most susceptible to his
to his
and so the first thing we are supposed
to do is run
but then there is
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
ان شاء الله نسال الله سبحانه سبحانه
وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يقينا فتنه
المسيح الدجال نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يحفظنا منه جميعا اللهم اعصمنا من فتنه
المسيح الدجال اللهم اعصمنا من فتنه
المسيح الدجال والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد ميك سنه صلاه
our تراويح
[Silence]
‏M.
استووا اعتدلوا
الله
اكبر اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ونبئهم عن ضيف ابراهيم
اذ دخلوا عليه فقالوا سلاما
قال انا منكم وجلون
قالوا لا توجل اننا نبشرك بقلام عليم
قال ابشرتموني
على ان مسني الكبر فبما تبشرون
قالوا بشرناك بالحق فلا تكن من القانطين
قال ومن قنط من رحمه ربه الا الضالون
قال فما خطبكم ايها المرسلون
قالوا انا ارسلنا الى قوم مجرمين
الا ال لوط انا لمنجوهم
اجمعين
الا امراته انا قدرنا انها لمن الغابرين
فلما جاء ال لوط المرسلون
قال انكم قوم منكرون
قالوا بل جئناك بما كانوا فيه يمترون
واتيناك بالحق وانا
لصادقون
فاسر باهلك بقطع من الليل ولا فاسر باهلك
بقطع من الليل ولا
فاسر باهلك بقطع من الليل واتبع ادبارهم
ولا يلتفت منكم
احد وامضوا حيث تؤمرون
وقضينا اليه ذلك الامر ان دابر هؤلاء
مقطوع
مصبحين
وجاء
اهل المدينه يستبشرون
قال ان هؤلاء
ضيفي فلا تفضحون
قالوا اولم ننهك عن العالمين
الله
[Arabic recitation]
ضيفي فلا تفضحون
واتقوا الله ولا تخزون
قالوا اولم ننهك عن العالمين
قال هؤلاء
بناتي ان كنتم فاعلين
لعمرك انهم لفي في سكرتهم يعمهون
فاخذتهم الصيحه مشرقين
فجعلنا عاليها سافلها
وامطرنا عليهم حجاره من سجيل
ان في ذلك لايات
للمتوسمين
وانها لبسبيل
مقيم
ان في ذلك لايه للمؤمنين
وان كان اصحاب الايكه لظالمين
فانتقمنا
منهم وانهما
لبامام
مبين
ولقد كذب اصحاب الحجر المرسلين
واتيناهم
اياتنا فكانوا عنها معرطين
وكانوا ينحتون من الجبال بيوتا امنين
فاخذتهم الصيحه مصبحين فما اغنى عنهم ما
كانوا يكسبون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما بينهما الا
بالحق
وان الساعه لاتيه
فاصفح الصفح الجميل
ان فاصفح الصفح الجميل ان ربك هو الخلاق
العليم
ولقد اتيناك سبعا من المثاني والقران
العظيم عظيم
لا تمدن عينيك الى ما متعنا به ازواجا
منهم
لا تتب لا تمدن عينيك الى ما متعنا به
ازواجا منهم ولا تحزن عليهم واخفض جناحك
للمؤمنين
وقل اني
انا النذير المبين
كما انزلنا
على المقتسم
على المقتسمين
الذين جعلوا القران عظين
فوربك لنسالنهم
اجمعين عما كانوا يعملون
فاصدع بما تؤمر واعرض رض عن المشركين
انا كفيناك
المستهزئين
الذين يجعلون مع الله الها اخر فسوف
يعلمون
ولقد نعلم انك يضيق صدرك بما يقولون
فسبح بحمد ربك وكن
من الساجدين
واعبد ربك حتى ياتيك اليقين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
اتى امر الله فلا تستعجل
سبحانه وتعالى عما يشركون
ينزل الملائكه
بالروح من امره على من يشاء من عباده
ان انذروا انه لا اله الا انا فاتقون
خلق السماوات والارض بالحق تعالى عما
يشركون
خلق الانسان من نطفه
فاذا هو خصيم مبين
والانعام خلقها
لكم فيها دفء ومنافع ومنها تاكلون
ولكم فيها جمال حين ولكم ولكم فيها جمال
حين تريحون وحين تسرحون
وتحمل اثقالكم الى بلد لم تكونوا بالغيه
الا بشق الانفس
ان ربكم لرؤوف رحيم
والخيل والبغال والحميم لتركبوها
وزينه وزينه
ويخلق ما لا تعلمون
وعلى الله قصد السبيل ومنها جائر
ولو شاء
لهداكم اجمعين
هو الذي انزل من السماء
ماء
لكم منه شراب
لكم منه شراب ومنه شجر فيه تسيمون
ينبت لكم به الزرع والزيتون والنخيل
والاعناب
والنخيل والاعناب ومن كل الثمرات
ان في ذلك لايه لقوم يتفكرون
وسخر وسخر لكم الليل والنهار والشمس
والقمر والنجوم مسخرات
بامره
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يعقلون
وما ذرا لكم في الارض مختلفا الوانه
ان في ذلك لايه لقوم يذكرون
وهو الذي سخر لكم البحر لتاكلوا منه لحما
طريا
وتستخرجوا منه حليه تلبسونها
وترى الفلك مواخر فيه ولتبتغوا من فضله
ولعلكم تشكرون
والقى في الارض رواسي ان تميد بكم وانهارا
وسبلا لعلكم تهتدون
وعلامات
وبالنجم هم يهتدون
افمن يخلق كمن لا يخلق افلا تذكرون
وان تعدوا نعمه الله لا تحصوها
ان الله لغفور رحيم
والله يعلم ما تسرون وما تعلمون
والذين يدعون من دون الله لا يخلقون شيئا
وهم يخلقون
اموات غير احياء
وما يشعرون ايان يبعثون
الهكم اله
واحد فالذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره قلوبهم
منكره
وهم مستكبرون
لا جرم
ان الله يعلم ما يسرون وما يعلنون
انه
لا يحب المستكبرين
واذا قيل لهم ماذا انزل ربكم قالوا اساطير
الاولين
ليحملوا اوزارهم كامله
يوم القيامه
ومن اوزار الذين يضلونهم
بغير علم الا ساء
ما يزرون
قد مكر الذين من قبلهم فات الله بنيانهم
من القواعد فخر عليهم السقف
فخر عليهم السقف من فوقهم واتاهم العذاب
من حيث لا يشعرون
ثم يوم القيامه يخزيهم ويقول
ويقول لهم ويقول اين شركائي
الذين كنتم تشاقون
فيهم
قال الذين اوتوا العلم ان الخزي اليوم
والسوء
على الكافرين
الذين تتوفاهم
الملائكه
ظالمي انفسهم
فالقوا السلم ما كنا
نعمل من سوء
بلى ان الله عليم بما كنتم تعملون
فادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين فيها
خالدين فيها فبئس مثوى المتكبرين
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وقيل للذين اتقوا ماذا انزل ربكم قالوا
خيرا للذين احسنوا في هذه الدنيا حسنه
ولدار الاخره خير
فلن ولنعم دار المتقين
جنات
عدن
عدن يدخلونها
جنات عدن يدخلونها
تجري من تحتها الانهار
لهم فيها ما يشاءون
كذلك يجزي الله المتقين
الذين تتوفاهم
الملائكه
طيبين
الذين تتوفاهم
الملائكه
طيبين يقولون سلام عليكم ادخلوا الجنه بما
كنتم تعملون
هل ينظرون الا ان تاتيهم الملائكه
ان تاتيهم الملائكه
او ياتي امر ربك كذلك فعل على الذين من
قبلهم وما ظلمنا ولكن كانوا انفسهم يظلمون
فاصابهم سيئات ما عملوا وحاق بهم ما كانوا
به يستهزئون
وقال الذين اشركوا لو شاء الله ما عبدنا
من دونه من شيء
ما عبدنا من دونه من شيء نحن ولا اباؤنا
ولا حرمنا من دونه من شيء
كذلك فعل الذين من قبلهم فهل على الرسل
الا البلاغ المبين ولقد بعثنا في كل امه
رسولا ان اعبدوا الله
ان اعبدوا الله واجتنبوا الطاغوت
فمنهم من هدى الله ومنهم
من حقت عليه الضلاله
فسيروا في الارض فانظروا كيف كان عاقبه
المكذبين
ان تحرص على هداهم
ان تحرص على هداهم فان الله لا يهدي من
يضل وما لهم من ناصرين
واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لا يبعث الله
من يموت بلى وعدا عليه حقا
ولكن
اكثر الناس لا يعلمون
ليبين لهم الذي يختلفون فيه وليعلم الذين
كفروا انهم كانوا كاذبين
انما قولنا لشيء اذا اردناه ان نقول له كن
فيكون
والذين الذين هاجروا في الله من بعد ما
ظلموا لنبوئهم
لنبوئهم
في الدنيا حسنه ولاجر الاخره اكبر لو
كانوا يعلمون
الذين صبروا وعلى ربهم يتوكلون
وما ارسلنا من قبلك الا رجالا نوحي اليهم
نوحي اليهم فاسالوا اهل الذكر ان كنتم لا
تعلمون
بالبينات
والزبر وانزلنا
اليك الذكر لتبين للناس ما نزل اليهم
ولعلهم يتفكرون
افامن الذين نكروا السيئات ان يخسف الله
بهم الارض او تات او ياتيهم العذاب من حيث
لا يشعرون
او ياخذهم في تقلبهم فما هم بمعجزين
او ياخذهم على تخوف فان ربكم لر رؤوف رحيم
اولم يروا الى ما خلق الله من شيء يتفي
ظلاله
يتفي ظلاله عن اليمين والشمائل
سجدا لله
سجدا لله وهم داخرون
ولله يسجد ما في السماوات وما في الارض من
دابه
ولله يسجد من في السماوات ومن في الارض من
والملائكه
وهم لا يستكبرون
ولله يسجد جد ما في السماوات وما في الارض
من دابه
والملائكه
وهم لا يستكبرون
يخافون ربهم من فوقهم
ويفعلون ما يؤمرون
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
المفروض ما
المفروض ما فوق
[Arabic recitation]
النحل
لا اله الا الله
نعمه
لا اله الاواعوادوا
[Silence]
استووا ذا
الله اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وقال الله لا تتخذوا الهين اثنين انما هو
اله واحد فاياي فارهبون
وله ما في السماوات والارض وله الدين
واصبا افغير الله تتقون
وما بكم من نعمه فمن الله
ثم اذا مسكم الضر فاليه تجارون
ثم اذا كشف الضر وعنكم اذا فريق منكم
بربهم يشركون
ليكفروا بما اتيناهم فتمتعوا فسوف تعلمون
ويجعلون لله ما يكر ويجعلون
ويجعلون لما لا يعلمون نصيبا مما رزقناهم
تله لتسالن
عما ما كنتم تفترون ويجعلون لله البنات
سبحانه ولهم ما يشتهون
واذا بشر احدهم بالانثى ظل وجهه مسودا وهو
كذب
يتوارى من القوم من سوء ما بشر به ايمسكه
على هون ام يدسه في التراب
الا ساء ما يحكمون
للذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره مثل السوء ولله
المثل الاعلى وهو العزيز الحكيم
ولو يؤاخذ الله الناس بظلمهم ما ترك عليها
من دابه
ولكن يؤخرهم الى اجل مسمى
فاذا جاء اجلهم لا يستاخر خرون ساعه ولا
يستقدمون
ويجعلون لله ما يكرهون وتصف السنتهم الكذب
ان لهم الحسنى
لا جرم ان لهم النار وانهم مفرطون
تله لقد ارسلنا الى امم من قبلك فزين لهم
الشيطان اعمالهم
فزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فهو وليه اليوم
ولهم عذاب اليم
وما انزلنا عليك الكتاب الا لتبين لهم
الذي اختلفوا فيه وهدى ورحمه
وهدى ورحمه لقوم يؤمنون
والله انزل من السماء ماء
فاحيا به الارض بعد موتها ان في ذلك لايه
لقوم يسمعون
وان لكم في الانعام لعبره نسقيكم مما في
بطونه من بين فرث ودم لبنا خالصا سائغا
للشاربين
ومن ثمرات النخيل والاعناب تتخذون منه
سكرا ورزقا حسنا
ان في ذلك لايه لقوم يعقلون
واوحى ربك الى النحل ان اتخذي من الجبال
بيوتا ومن الشجر ومما يعرشون
ثم كلي من كل الثمرات فاسلكي سبل ربك ذللا
يخرج من بطونها شراب مختلف الوانه فيه
شفاء
للناس
ان في ذلك لايه لقوم يتفكرون
والله خلقكم ثم يتوفاكم
ومنكم من يرد الى ارذل العمر لكي لا يعلم
بعد علم شيئا ان الله عليم قدير
والله خلقكم ثم يتوفاكم ومنكم من يرد الى
ارذل العمر لكي لا يعلم لكي لا يعلم بعد
علم شيئا ان الله عليم قدير
والله فضل بعضكم على بعض في الرزق فما
الذين فضلوا برادي
رزقهم على ما ملكت ايمانهم فهم فيه سواء
افبنعمه الله يجحدون
والله جعل لكم من انفسكم ازواجا وجعل لكم
من ازواجكم بنين وحفده ورزقكم من الطيبات
افبالباطل يؤمنون وبنعمه الله هم يكفرون
ويعبدون من دون الله ما لا يملك لهم رزقا
من السماوات والارض شيئا ولا يستطيعون
فلا تضربوا لله الامثال
ان الله يعلم وانتم لا تعلمون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
فلا تضربوا لله الامثال
ان الله يعلم وانتم لا تعلمون
ضرب الله مثلا عبدا مملوكا لا يقدر على
شيء ومن رزقناه منا رزقا حسنا فهو ينفق
منه سرا وجهرا
هل يستوون
الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا يعلمون
وضرب الله الرجلين احدهما ابكم لا يقدر
على شيء وهو كل على مولاه
اينما يوجهه لا يات بخير هل يستوي هو ومن
يامر بالعدل وهو على صراط مستقيم
ولله غيب السماوات والارض وما امر الساعه
الا كلمح البصر او واقرب ان الله على كل
شيء قدير
والله اخرجكم من بطون امهاتكم لا تعلمون
شيئا وجعل لكم السمع والابصار والافئده
لعلكم تشكرون
الم يروا الى الطير مسخرات في جو السماء
ما يمسكهن
الا الله
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يؤمنون
والله جعل لكم من بيوتكم سكنا وجعل لكم من
جنود الانعام بيوتا تستخفونها يوم ضعنكم
ويوم اقامتكم
ومن اصوافها واوبارها واشعارها اثاثا
ومتاعا الى حين
والله والله جعل لكم مما خلق ظلا وجعل لكم
من الجبال اكنانا
وجعل لكم سرابيل تقيكم الحر وسرابيل تقيكم
باسكم كذلك يتم
عليكم لعلكم تسلمون
فان تولوا فانما عليك البلاغ المبين
يعرفون نعمه الله ثم ينكرونها
واكثرهم الكافرون
ويوم نبعث من كل امه شهيدا ثم لا يؤذن
للذين كفروا ولا هم يستعتبون
واذا راى الذين ظلموا العذاب فلا يخفف
عنهم ولا هم ينظرون
واذا راى الذين اشركوا شركاءهم
قالوا ربنا هؤلاء شركاؤنا
الذين كنا
قالوا ربنا هؤلاء
شركاؤنا
الذين كنا ندعو من دونك
فالقوا اليهم القول انكم لكاذبون
والق قوا الى الله يومئذ السلم وضل عنهم
ما كانوا يفترون
الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله زدناهم
عذابا فوق العذاب بما كانوا يفسدون
ويوم نبعث في كل امه شهيدا عليهم من
انفسهم وجئنا بك شهيدا على هؤلاء
ونزلنا عليك الكتابا
لكل شيء وهدى ورحمه
وهدى ورحمه وبشرى للمسلمين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي
القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعذكم لعلكم تذكرون
واوفوا بعهد الله اذا عاهدتم ولا تنقضوا
الايمان بعد توكيدها وقد جعلتم الله عليكم
كفيلا
ان الله يعلم ما تفعلون
ولا تكونوا كالتي نقضت غزلها من بعد قوه
انكاثا
تتخذون ايمانكم دخلا بينكم ان تكون امه هي
ارب
يبلوكم الله به وليبينن
لكم يوم القيامه ما كنتم فيه تختلفون
ولو شاء الله لجعلكم امه واحده ولكن يضل
من يشاء ويهدي من يشاء
ولتسالن عما كنتم تعملون
ولا تتخذوا ايمانكم دخلا بينكم فتزل قدم
بعد ثبوتها وتذوق السوء بما صددتم عن سبيل
الله ولكم عذاب عظيم
ولا تشتروا بعهد الله ثمنا قليلا
انما عند الله هو خير لكم ان كنتم تعلمون
ما عندكم ينفد وما عند الله باق ولنجزين
الذين صبروا اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا يعملون
من عمل صالحا من ذكر او انثى وهو مؤمن
فلنحيينه
حياه طيبه
فلنحيين
ه حياه طيبه
ولنجزينهم
اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا يعملون
فاذا قرات القران فاستعذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم انه
ليس له سلطان على الذين امنوا وعلى ربهم
يتوكلون
انما سلطانه على الذين يتولونه والذين هم
به مشركون
واذا بدلنا ايه مكان ايه والله اعلم بما
ينزل قالوا انما انت مفتر بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون
قل نزله روح القدس من ربك بالحق ليثبت
الذين امنوا وهدى وبش شر للمسلمين
ولقد نعلم انهم يقولون انما يعلمه بشر
لسان الذي يلحدون اليه اعجمي
وهذا لسان عربي مبين
ان الذين لا يؤمنون بايات الله لا يهديهم
الله واولئك هم الكافرون
الله ولهم عذاب اليم
انما يفتري الكذب الذين لا يؤمنون بايات
الله
واولئك هم الكاذبون
من كفر بالله من بعد ايمانه الا من اكره
وقلبه
مطمئن
بالايمان
ولكن من شرح بالكفر صدرا فعليهم غضب من
الله ولهم عذاب عظيم
ذلك بانهم استحبوا الحياه الدنيا على
الاخره وان الله لا يهدي القوم الكافرين
اولئك الذين طبع الله على قلوبهم وس سمعهم
وابصارهم واولئك
هم الغافلون
لا جرم انهم في الاخره هم الخاسرون
ثم ان ربك للذين هاجروا من بعد ما فتنوا
ثم جاهدوا وصبروا
ان ربك من بعدها لغفور رحيم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد وايا اياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يوم تاتي كل نفس تجادل عن نفسها وتوفى كل
نفس ما عملت وهم لا يظلمون
وضرب الله مثلا قريه كانت امنه مطمئنه
ياتيها رزقها رغدا من كل مكان
فكفرت بانعم الله فاذاقها الله لباس الجوع
والخوف بما كانوا يصنعون
ولقد قد جاءهم رسول منهم فكذبوه
فاخذهم العذاب وهم ظالمون
فكلوا مما رزقكم الله حلالا طيبا واشكروا
نعمه الله ان كنتم اياه تعبدون
انما حرم عليكم الميته والدم ولحم الخنزير
وما اهل وما
لغير الله به فمن اضطر غير باغ ولا عاد
فان الله غفور رحيم
ولا تقولوا لما تصف السنتكم الكذب هذا
حلال وهذا حرام لتفتروا على الله الكذب ان
الذين يفترون على الله الكذب لا يفلحون
متاع قليل قليل ولهم عذاب اليم
وعلى الذين هادوا حرمنا ما قصصنا عليك من
قبل وما ظلمناهم ولكن كانوا انفسهم يظلمون
ثم ان ربك للذين عملوا السوء بجهاله ثم
تابوا من بعد ذلك واصلحوا
ان ربك من بعدها لغفور رحيم
ان ابراهيم كان امه قانتا لله حنيفا ولم
يك من المشركين
شاكرا لانعمه
اجتباه وهداه الى صراط مستقيم
واتيناه في الدنيا حسنه وانه في الاخره
لمن الصالحين
ثم اوحينا اليك ان اتبع مله ابراهيم حنيفا
وما كان من المشركين
انما جعل السبت على الذين اختلفوا فيه وان
ربك ليحكم بينهم يوم القيامه فيما كانوا
فيه يختلفون
ادعوا الى سبيل لربك بالحكمه والموعظه
الحسنه وجادلهم بالتي هي احسن ان ربك هو
اعلم بمن ضل عن سبيله وهو اعلم بالمهتدين
وان عاقبتم فعاقبوا بمثل ما عوقبتم به
ولئن صبرتم لهو خير للصابرين
واصبر وما صبرك الا بالله
ولا تحزن عليهم ولا تك في ضيق مما يمكرون
ان الله مع الذين اتقوا والذين هم محسنون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
تعال
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الض ضالين
امين
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي
قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى
فجعله غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم
لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل يا ايها الكافرون لا اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
ولا انا عابد ما عبدتم
لكم دينكم ولي دين
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
جزاك الله خيرا احسنت واصدت
تباركت